you've all heard the expression ladies
and gentlemen this is a television first
tonight we have with us an Academy Award
first the winner of the very first Oscar
presented by the Academy the very lovely
and charming Miss Jeanette Gaynor
Dana welcome and I'm sure you can tell
by the applause how we all feel about
you thank you very much - you're welcome
I'm very proud of that first golden
statue that I took home so many years
ago and through these years I've watched
Oscar grow into this world-famous young
man and now for the nominations for the
Best Motion Picture of the year they are
around the world in 80 days produced by
Michael Todd friendly persuasion
produced by William Wyler giant produced
by George Stevens and Henry Ginsburg the
King and I produced by Charles Brackett
the Ten Commandments produced by settle
B DeMille
around the world
on behalf of the 60 some odd thousand
people who made the show around the
world
thanks for myself I'm especially
thrilled I'm Connor because this is my
first time at bat here thank you
well it's about time to lock up the
store and I would like to thank mr. left
home in New York for doing a very
admirable job how about I can't so let's
go
I'd like to thank everyone at the
Academy and I certainly feel that the
American public should know of the great
job that mr. Johnny Greene did tonight
with the wonderful Orchestra Johnny
thank you good night from Hollywood and
thank you for being a wonderful audience
we hope we will see you next year
hold the bill thank you I thank you good
night and gentlemen the Motion Picture
Academy Awards presentations have been
brought to you by the Oldsmobile
Division of General Motors Corporation
we sincerely congratulate all of
tonight's Oscar winners and we hope that
all of you on our TV audience have
enjoyed this exciting event as much as
we have here at the Pantages Theatre in
Hollywood and we hope too that you
enjoyed our Oldsmobile Fiesta tours
during the intermissions and I'd like to
remind you that your nearby Oldsmobile
dealer invite you to stop in tomorrow
and see his big special spring showing
of new 1957 Oldsmobiles including the
fabulous Fiesta you'll find there's a
rocket for every pocket and when you
visit your dealer be sure to try the new
j2 rocket engine you've never known
anything like it so tomorrow make a date
with your authorized oldsmobile quality
dealer be his guest for a j2 rocket test
and enjoy the performance of the year
and now speaking for Oldsmobile this is
Bob lemon wishing you all a very good
night
this has been an NBC television
presentation